you may have seen the news i covered a
little bit uh earlier today consumer
prices jumped five percent in may at the
fastest this is the fastest pace since
the summer of 2008 just before the
market went
they say headline consumer prices rose
five percent year year-over-year in may
the fastest pace since august 2008 and
higher than wall street expectations the
3.8 rise in the core inflation rate
which excludes foods and energy prices
was the sharpest increase in nearly
three decades
surging used car prices helped drive
much of the inflation gains initial
jobless claims totaled 376 000 a touch
higher than the estimate
i don't know exactly what's going to
happen you got a bunch of weird articles
and you can't really believe the news
this is an official official number
maybe it's lower maybe the number's a
lot higher we had max kaiser on the show
many of you are probably familiar with
max he's the orange pill podcast guy and
he's very very bullish on bitcoin he
said the inflation rate's probably
closer to 10 or 15 percent but the fed's
not going to tell you the government's
not going to let you know because that
would disrupt a whole bunch of the
system and uh interest rates uh social
security payouts so they're going to try
and say it's as low as possible do we
trust the mainstream media after
everything i've seen in the past five
years no how do i know this article
about the seat the consumer price index
is even real maybe there is no consumer
price index i don't even know what to
believe at this point but we do have
this other article which i found
interesting this is an op-ed from the
seattle times don't ignore the warnings
of an imminent market crash
this guy says harry s denton jr has been
a soothsayer of sadness and gloom for
ages now and has spent a lot of time on
the wrong side of the record of the
record bull market recovery since the
financial crisis of 2008. currently he
is calling for the stock market to crash
with lightning speed potentially
starting within the next six weeks now i
don't know if that's true it sounds a
bit outlandish it's probably one of the
more more uh
i guess doom saying stories that are out
there because if you read mainstream
media they're telling everybody it's all
gonna be okay they're like oh yeah it's
just you know demand hasn't caught up to
supply yet and once it does it's gonna
be a big boom for everybody
but uh something doesn't feel right it
feels just like i wasn't there but right
before the great depression 1920. it
just this i was studying it it's like
this is what happened the inflation
starts it and it happened the crash is
like a three-month process or or of
several it's a multi-month it doesn't
just happen in three days and so we're
probably in the middle of it right now
it's why we're seeing 15 percent
inflation across the board how many how
many people have been talking about with
the have you been following the gamestop
amc stock
sure now i think there's a potential
danger there of course there's the
they're saying it's gonna be a big short
sale everyone's gonna make tons of money
i have some amc stock so we'll see but i
don't have a lot of risk i'm not exposed
all that much i don't have that much
money i have you know a little bit of
amc stock not a whole lot
and a lot of people are leveraging hard
for these meme stocks and you know ian's
saying it's a lot like the great
depression yes what happens when a bunch
of working-class people put tons of
money in to say like dogecoin or
something or or these meme stocks and
they leverage hard against it so you've
got some people have said they've
leveraged all their assets and their
credit lines to buy like 100k in amc
because they know it's going to go up
what happens when that pops what if
there's a market crash in six weeks is
that what's happening you think i mean
is that you think people are getting i
mean i remember before there was some
concern
and not knowing enough about the market
there was some concern it seemed
legitimate that some people might be
getting lured into this
unwittingly do you think that some of
that's been happening you know
i don't know i'm bullish on crypto and
i'll tell you this if you look at the at
the market pre-2008 crash
the people who who held on to their
assets for dear life
they made out like bandits right the
market recovered and boom they're back
up but a lot of people
you know i i hear these stories i was
not alive during the great depression
and believe it or not i'm only 35. but
so the stories i heard was that people
were making all this money in the stock
market and so once they saw how everyone
else was getting rich they started
buying on margin they started you know
leveraging their assets and credits to
buy all the stock and then when it
dropped they were like my life is over
so what if that's happening now yeah
what if these people think
and i don't i don't want to be bearish
on on these on these things look i
bought amc i'm actually of the opinion
it's probably going to go up and it's
the hedge funds that are going to eat it
but if the hedge funds eat it and they
get a bailout i mean there's going to be
a massive wave of something that hits
everybody well i think this comes back
to what you're talking about about
before with the houses in real estate i
think that people
even though they're trying to warn
people don't don't worry about anything
people see the signs people see what's
happening with inflation and what are
people doing people want to buy houses
even though they understand that with
inflation
with inflation the value is going to
take a hit but that's something that's
long term and i hear people all the time
friends not necessarily
finance professionals but saying put
your money in something real that's
going to last we know that we know
different commodities like artwork
even things i hear people talking about
not just bitcoin baseball cards things
like that you see those nfts no
non-fungible oh right right people are
spending ridiculous amounts of money on
nonsense yeah so i gotta i gotta wonder
man if you got a bunch of young people
right now so i mean i think about this
like
who are these people who are who are the
retail investors that are investing
heavily in crypto and these meme stocks
and what if what if there is a market
crash i mean we're looking at consumer
prices skyrocketing people are worried
about the dollar
i don't know
i don't know
it's the margin it's the margins that
make me nervous so i i bought a bunch of
crypto ethereum and then i took out a
loan to buy more ethereum basically a
margin on margin um with my own crypto
and so the the ethereum went from like
1100 to 800 value and they were like
margin call if this goes to 700 we're
gonna have to sell all your ethereum and
pay pay back the loan you took out and i
started to sweat it went back up as i
had anticipated and i was lucky and i
just i just cleared my margin i can't
i'm not sitting on a margin right now
like yeah if it if the economy crashes
it will recover so if you're holding
assets you'll be they'll still recover
but if you're holding on margin they do
a call
and then they take everything from you
that's yeah and i can't give advice but
that's what i did was i cleared my
margins
it's creepy
i don't know i mean maybe the meme
stocks are just going to skyrocket but
it's it's it's beyond all this it's not
just you know the the the crypto or
stuff it's joe biden you know they're
still they're still doing this 300 a
week unemployment stimulus thing but i
think around like 30 states or so have
like now canceled it right because
people got it back to work but a lot of
the red states are a lot of the red
states are trying to block this get
people back to work
uh in the state we are we're in now
south carolina the governor you know the
governor has at least tried to put his
foot down and i think that's happening
in other red states too people are cons
people are concerned about it how are we
going to get americans back to work how
are we going to because you can see it
also undermining local and state
economies as well it's really dangerous
yeah i have to wonder when you look at
some of these charts
there is a
vaccination chart we talked about a
couple times npr put it out the states
the highest rate of vaccination are all
blue the state with the lowest
vaccination are all red
the only states that defy that anomaly
are the states that you know trump and
trump supporters are contesting for the
you know in the election which is also
you know just kind of a funny thing to
point out but i i have to wonder you
know the red states are clearly defiant
to the blue states
the blue states want hard lockdowns they
want command economy they want total
economic control
at what point do the red states just say
no
because i with texts in florida
reopening and banning vaccine passports
clearly clearly they're telling biden to
go shove it but i mean can this keep up
for the next few years what happens when
you know as i point i pointed this out
the other day if someone who lives in
texas can't go to to washington because
they have vaccine passports right so i i
just bring it up in the context of you
know where we're at economically and how
what what did we see before covet these
blue states were in massive debt they
were they were failing and spiraling and
then all of a sudden we get coveted then
as soon as joe biden gets in he starts
handing out all the cash which is a tax
on people in those red states
taking the money from the middle class
devaluing their currency in their
savings account yeah it's reparations
and
in a sense but to the wealthy blue
states right
um no it's brutal because also it's it's
it's also it's it's not just political
payoff right you're hurting also your
enemies right you're taking the money
from you're taking the money from red
states and handing it off to blue states
and why because
because
even though that you destroyed your city
even though you were part of rioting
last spring and summer and you tore your
city to shreds don't worry joe biden's
got the bill don't worry you can keep
this all closed don't worry people don't
have to work because uncle joe's
covering it yeah it was basically like
uh let them burn everything down blame
it on trump and then joe biden will
cover the debts absolutely they
sacrificed the people of this uh of this
country for political gain so
how long until the red states are just
like nah
ain't doing it i mean i don't know
what's happening now i mean it's
interesting are people saying
are people saying yeah just you know if
you're going to come here you know if
you're going to come here behave
yourself if you're going to come to the
red states going to come to florida i
mean what florida is still getting they
must still be getting maybe more a
thousand a thousand new residents a day
so who's going down there and and in
texas
the rumor is you can't buy a house
anywhere everyone's just desperately
trying to buy everything up in texas
right but but you i think about the
conundrum here is that
you know washington new york they're
starting to increase the vaccine
passport things they're putting
restrictions on who can come there while
texas and florida are doing the opposite
that means these blue states will be
able to reap the benefits and the
rewards of the labor of these red states
not the other way around right it's it's
it's we're getting we're getting to this
dangerous point where
i mean we're really close to
neo-feudalism do people want to i mean
it's do people do people want to go to
new york right when you're saying i
can't go to new york unless i have a
covet password i'll say okay
i won't go to where you are what if you
work for american airlines out of uh
that's dallas fort worth that's bad
right and you fly into you got to fly in
for
a meeting they say okay so we got a you
know senior vp in dallas hey we got a
meeting with uh uh you know someone from
the new york you know
jfk administration or whatever port
authority
it might be it might be an exciting time
in the country politically where the
states start reasserting what they're
about and you have therefore
you have uh the the governor of texas
and others saying
stepping up for american airlines if
that's the way it's going to go staying
stepping up and saying we're looking out
for our business as well and we
understand and here's how we're going to
push back against new york if new york
tries to hurt our business
our business people we're going to push
back on them
in this way but i think the problem is
it's always going to it's always going
to favor those who are the the
the most stubborn in terms of the
negotiation right so if new york says
look the people of new york demand the
excelsior pass if you want to come here
and go into this building you need your
pass and then texas can complain all
they want and new york will be like look
you want business from us
what are you going to do about it the
issue is you've got stubborn new york
making a demand and you've got more
libertarian or libertarianesque dallas
fort worth you know people saying
fine we'll just do it it's easier and we
get the deal done so the pressure from
the stubborn states will work on those
who are less concerned about some of
these issues it's easier in some ways if
texas voters for instance i mean this is
you know for instance if texas voters
say if you make that deal you're in big
trouble if the governor makes that deal
and it's going to force us to conduct
our business no no i don't mean that i
mean american airlines employee right
he's got a meeting in new york with some
big company for food or something new
york says you must be vaccinated you
must have your excelsior pass no one in
texas is going to force this guy to do
it he just literally can't do the
meeting right and so what will happen is
the employees at american airlines will
just choose to abide by new york law
yeah this is this is a big thing that's
going to compel different people if
they're living makes it
you know if they're living depends on
whether or not they have to get this
shot but maybe there will be different
consortiums of states maybe texas and
florida
uh and idaho
will say uh
you know we'll find some way to team
together
and and and break some of the power of
some of the coastal some of the coastal
powers yeah uh maybe i just think
everyone takes the path of least
resistance or most people do so long as
new york puts these heavy pressures on
people if they want money and access
they'll just give in to whatever new
york wants
or washington or whatever state they got
operated right it can be relaxed in new
york but they will just set the standard
for the for the most difficult so my
concern at this point is maybe you're
right maybe a bunch of states from
regional compacts
aren't we just talking about states
aligning against states yeah i mean we
saw that in 2020 yeah 48 states were
involved in lawsuits against each other
right that was crazy
yeah right that's what it's in in a
sense it's kind of an interesting time
so may you live in an interesting time
yeah well i don't want it to be that
interesting of course um
you know but i mean look if we talk all
the time about how dire things are how
drastic things are
uh what kind of times what what kind of
interesting times we're living in then
the very least people are gonna have to
stand up and say like you know what i
don't know i'm gonna have to make a
decision do i want to get this shot to
be able to do business in new york or
how do i get around this or what are the
different uh compacts i'm going to make
with colleagues
with with political powers how are we
going to push back on this thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you